tri pour en parler nous sommes avec pas
louis une présidents des républiques and
friends bonsoir pèlerine merci d'être
avec nous à vos côtés jean-claude
beaujour vice président du cercle de
réflexion france-amérique avocat en
droit international également
bonsoir à vous est également jean-claude
beaujour on l'a vu un ces images en ont
créé une onde de choc dans la classe
politique américaine condamnations
unanimes y compris dans votre partie par
le rina les républicains je vous propose
avant de vous faire réagir d'écouté 8
ramener un ancien candidat comme vous
connaissez évidemment des républicains à
l'élection présidentielle de 2012 ce qui
s'est passé ici aujourd'hui est une
insurrection provoqué par le président
des états unis
ceux qui choisissent de continuer à
soutenir son dangereux stratagème en
s'opposant aux résultats d'une élection
légitime et démocratique seront à jamais
considéré comme complice d'une attaque
sans précédent contre notre démocratie
voilà des propos assez claire de mitt
romney qui ne soutient pas donald trump
pèlerine quand vous avez vu ces images
qu est ce que vous avez ressenti est ce
que vous soutenez toujours avec autant
de ferveur donald trump ce soir c'est
pas les bons images ça c'est sûr c'est
les mêmes images présentes
nous condamnons un taux de violence des
termes toutefois possible et tous les
violences le pâtis du public un devis
lancée contre les principes de la partie
du public 1 et on a toujours comme dans
l violence qui étaient dans les rues par
les gauchistes dans le dernier 9 12 mois
et en condamnant très fort cette
violence aussi par les républicains et
c'est pas bon
qu'ils ont forcé l'entrée dans le
capital et c'est vraiment pas bien
c'est tout ce que je peux dire là alors
on se pose évidemment beaucoup de
questions à 24 heures après
ces violences pourquoi on en est arrivé
là les militantes contre 1 parce qu'on a
sous-estimé leur colère avant de vous
faire réagir vous aussi jean-claude
bonjour je vous propose d'écouter ces
manifestants trump est un leader il
défend le monde libre il défend le droit
et si j'étais à sa place je ferais la
même chose je sens que j'étais censé
être ici alors on est allé à l'intérieur
parce que je crois que dieu voulait que
j'y sois
et elle est venue pour soutenir maman
exigeons que les élections soient
intègres et nous pensons que le prix
d'entrée a gagné et nous n'allons pas
seulement dire et accepter la tricherie
nous devons envoyer un message au
congrès
nous voulons reprendre le pays c'est
notre maison ils ont essayé de
barricader les gens et ils ont fait
tomber la barricade comme les kurdes en
actes elles sont éparpillées partout et
maintenant nous reprenons notre pays
je suis convaincu que trump a réellement
gagné l'élection et qu'il ya eu
suffisamment de tricherie et de fraudes
qui ont été balayés par qu'ils ne
veulent pas en entendre parler juste
arrêter ce vol de l'élection jean-claude
beaujour c'est important d'écouter ces
témoignages parce que on touche
peut-être le fond de ce problème en tout
cas c'est que de nombreux militants pro
trump sont convaincus qu'on leur a volé
leur victoire ils sont convaincus qu'il
ya eu tricherie
qu'est ce que vous répondez justement
quand on entend ces témoignages est ce
que vous comprenez un tout petit peu
mieux ce qui s'est passé hier soir vous
j'entends j'entends le témoignage de ces
personnes il est particulièrement
difficile d'argumenter sur le plan
résonner au raisonnable lorsque quelques
vous dis je suis convaincu
parce qu'il m'est difficile d'apporter
la preuve contraire on précisément parce
que la question n'est pas d'apporter la
preuve que l'élection s'est bien passé
lorsque dans un système et je vais vous
dire il n'y a pas qu'aux états unis où
il ya des problèmes lors de scrutins
électoraux
il existe aussi y compris en france
lorsque vous avez des problèmes sur des
scrutins électoraux vous porter ces
sujets devant les tribunaux et en tant
qu'avocat et praticiens il y à une
mécanique assez simple vous apportez vos
éléments de preuve
les juges examinent les éléments de
preuve recevables que vous avez et ils
apprécient le point suivant est ce que
lorsqu'il y a des éléments non cocordan
dans le respect de la procédure
on peut même imaginer une éventuelle
fraude
les juges apprécient si ces fraudes sont
de nature circonscription par
circonscription où est à paris tu as
donc circonscriptions électorales par
circonscription électorale
si c'est ces irrégularités ont pu
impacter le résultat définitif du
scrutin et donc donald trump et j'étais
le premier à dire sur vos plateaux que
le président avait le droit de contester
les élections dans les squats dans les
étapes pour lesquels dans lesquelles il
estimait qu'il y avait un souci est la
partenaire aux juges aux tribunaux de
trancher
c'est ce qu'il a fait et les tribunaux
en tranchée en démocratie on ne peut pas
se contenter chacun ne peut pas se
contenter et cela je le dirai que ce
soit un candidat républicain candidat
démocrate ou quel que soit le pays
on ne peut pas se contenter sur une
procédure de dire je crois où j'ai une
conviction alors malheureusement pour
cette personne en démocratie dans nos
systèmes
il y à il y à des tribunaux les dossiers
ont été portés et examinées par les
tribunaux il ya eu plus de 60 procédure
elles ont échoué il faute à un moment
donné on reconnaître les décisions qui
ont été rendus je voudrais vous préciser
que cette question je l'avais posé il ya
quelques années au vice-président trump
je leur ai dit monsieur le vice
président comment est ce que quand et
comment allez vous
j lorsque vous avez réalisé ou lorsque
vous avez dû du admet que vous alliez
perdre les élections vous les aviez
perdu du fait de ce problème en floride
et qu'effectivement les tribunaux vous
avez n'avait pas autorisé à ce que le
processus aille aille au delà il m'a dit
la chose suivante
à un moment donné il faut savoir
s'arrêter parce qu'il y va de l'avenir
de notre pays et un accord et
effectivement algorithmes paris nos
jours on parlait hier avec gérald
olivier en spécialiste des états unis
journalistes qui nous disait mémé ses
militants c'est vrai qu'ils ont été
méprisés souvent pas écouté alors ça
n'excuse pas mais est ce que c'est un
début d'explication à cette colère selon
vous mais méprisé excusez moi vous
pouvez spécifier ça oui ça veut dire
qu'ils n'ont pas été considérés écoutez
et et notamment dans les médias
américains c'était en tout cas l'analyse
hier de gerald de olivier qui apportait
peut-être un autre son de cloche chez un
début de lecture à ces événements oui le
problème une raison pour le colère et
qu' il y avait beaucoup d tribunal qui y
compris les courses prince qui n'a pas
accepté le cas ligue a présenté par par
l'équipe
les gars de chambre on croit que il
n'avait pas l'opportunité à présenter
toutes les évidences et 400 de tous les
américains qui croient que l'élection
était frauduleux y compris 17% des
démocrates en il ya une raison pour pour
avoir plus d audit plus des discussions
plus des décisions par lé tribunal cour
suprême comme dans le cas de 2000 et
avec al gore qui ne qui n'était pas se
passer donc les gens étaient vraiment en
colère et en mon avis justifiée et
et pas et pas il faut pas oublier que la
chose qui en comme d'hab en condamnant
la violence se tue à la capitale mais
les choses que connut les huit public un
envoi une double standard complète par
les médias et par les démocrates
on oublie que le lendemain de l'élection
de 2016 et avait les manifestations
violentes dans tous les grands villes
aux états unis il n'a jamais accepté que
tu as un petit président et pendant mes
dernières tout l'année 2020 et avait les
émeutes et les violences complète et les
700 policiers aux petits dans les
hôpitaux 35 gens tués et toujours 2018
il y avait des démocrates donc sur les
escaliers d'une capitale qu'ils ont
occupé les bureaux de la capitale
pendant la confirmation de broca
maintenant il ne me dira que c'est un
débat et les ouïes jean claude bourgeois
aléas les six mois je voudrais je pense
que là il ya il ya eu des
incompréhensions que des partisans
manifestent c'est leur droit il y à une
disposition constitue constitutionnelle
américaine qui consacre le droit le
droit à l'opinion le droit d'expression
cela n'est pas contestée là où il faut
qu'on se comprenne très bien c'est que
vous parliez de la cour suprême mais la
cour suprême
ce sont des magistrats qui sont
chevronnés la cour suprême de président
de 30 a nommé trois magistrats de sa
tendance politique y compris la dernière
nomination donc il a une majorité à cour
suprême vous savez je pense qu'à un
moment donné il faut ne pas simplement
se fier et je vous le dis sincèrement
comme avocat est aussi comme homme
engagé engagé en faveur de l'état de
droit
on ne peut pas diriger un pays on ne
peut pas avoir des structures où les
gens ont le
sentiments moi je vais vous dire ce qui
m'a choqué ou du moins ce qui m'a
surpris lorsque j'ai vu que l'avocat du
président trump mon confrère giuliani a
présenté un dossier quand il est apparu
quelques heures après quand il a décidé
qu'il allait engager des poursuites
en toute franchise le dossier était
pauvre c'est à dire que je n'aurais même
pas permis un collaborateur de présenter
un dossier aussi mal construit il a
laissé son client quand j'ai écouté le
président trump défendre son point et
moi j'entends celui nous avons
l'habitude
quant au devant des tribunaux d'entendre
les parties on se tait on entend ce que
c'est le principe du contradictoire
on entend toujours ce que dit une partie
on se tait on les écoute lorsque j'ai
entendu le président preuves mais mais
j'ai entendu comme un justiciable je me
suis dit mais pourquoi est ce que son
avocat n'a pas défendu son son dossier
parce que c'était mal construit c'est
juridiquement ça n'était pas bien
construit et ça ça n'est pas la faute
des démocrates
il appartenait à vos avocats de
présenter en tout cas dans ce que j'ai
entendu et j'ai lu certain nombre de
décisions
il appartenait à avaux avocats de
rapporter les preuves de d'être plus
construit moi je vous dise que quand
j'ai entendu le président trump alors
peut-être que la population le coin la
population l'a cru mais on ne fait pas
un dossier à partir du 10 3 ont fait un
dossier à partir de pièces et d'une
démonstration qui est parfois même le
peu mathématiques et je peux vous dire
qu'en la matière la démonstration doit
être mathématiques donc malheureusement
je chante en france ballerines pèlerine
aujourd'hui
vous êtes un républicain en feu l'un e s
que donald trump n'a pas tout perdu
finalement dans cette affaire ça sera ma
dernière question une bo de la fin pour
vous est-ce qu'il a tout perdu
non juste aux cheveux longs
oui ah oui on est un peu quand ils ont
un enfant mais ok c'est fini on va fait
une transition ordonnée
maintenant le moment que avec tous vos
entretiens avec les gens ont tout le
monde
le moment que deux chambres est passé il
est parti et le monde n'a pas quelqu'un
à des tests détesté au quotidien et met
le blâme sur tous les problèmes de monde
sur les épaules de notre shop les gens
va commencer à réfléchir surveiller tous
les bons sites qu'ils ont fait pendant
quatre ans c'était vraiment incroyable
tout ce qu'il y a réussi et j'espère
qu'ils vont commencer à avoir de vraies
durban ii ne badinait et rs et la
faiblesse de cette tique et de président
un vice-président
on verra s'il peut vraiment gérer tous
les problèmes du monde
comme tu chantes pas bien bien gérer
donc je suis toujours positif et a
toujours une grosse républicains qui
croient dans le principe de dopés par la
force de fisker mus possibilité fiscale
et tout ça à independence energy aux
états unis et on reste positive mais les
gens les républicains on va critiquer
les autres républicains tout formateur
on sera là en tout cas pour en parler
avec vous deux sur ce plateau et on vous
invitera évidemment pour commenter ce
ticket comme vous dites à risque byden
et voir un petit peu leurs résultats
dans les prochaines années merci à vous
deux part in
merci à genthod bonjour d'avoir été avec
nous